* Fröhliche, leichte Klänge *
Guten Morgen allerseits!
- (Alle) Guten Morgen.
Habt ihr alle gut geschlafen?
- (Alle) Ja.
Es gibt hauseigenen Honig
aus unserer Kleinimkerei,
Früchte haben wir auch.
Spiegeleier und Speck für alle?
Es hat auch Cappuccino, Latte
Macchiato, Ristretto und Espresso.
Eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf, sechs,
sieben, acht, neun, zehn, elf.
Es ist toll, den Gästen morgens
ein frisches Frühstück zuzubereiten
mit all den frischen Sachen.
Das macht richtig Spass.
Wir sind im Kopf schon am neuen Ort.
Irgendwann ist es Zeit, loszulassen.
Irgendwann beginnt etwas Neues.
Das sind vier Geschichten
rund um Menschen,
die sich
ans Abenteuer Nachfolge wagen.
So auch
die Jungbauernfamilie Wieland.
* Schrille Türklingel *
Guten Tag.
- Guten Tag.
Guten Tag, Sie sind Frau Wieland,
laut Foto in der Zeitung. - Genau.
Ich will Sie nicht stören.
- Kein Problem.
Wir sind durchgefahren
und ich wollte schauen kommen.
Wir vernahmen,
dass Sie wegziehen wollen? - Ja.
Wohin?
- Nach Röthenbach, in die Grub.
Wir übernehmen einen Milchwirt-
schaftsbetrieb mit 14 Milchkühen.
Dann sind wir dort.
- Schön.
Man kann ...
- Dann würden wir mal ...
Sie dürfen gerne Mal vorbeikommen.
Vom Konzept her ist es etwa gleich.
Sie sind jederzeit willkommen.
Vielen Dank, Frau Wieland.
- Danke Ihnen.
Einen schönen Tag
und alles Gute im neuen Zuhause.
Das ist nett, vielen Dank,
und auf bald! Alles Gute, danke.
Hier in Aeschau im Emmental
hat Familie Wieland
bisher zur Miete gewohnt
und immer
von einem eigenen Hof geträumt.
Wielands, das sind Thom, Salome
und seit ein paar Monaten Lilou.
Unter dem Namen Wielandleben
haben sie einen kleinen
Agrotourismusbetrieb aufgebaut.
Dazu gehört das Bewirten von Gästen,
ein Bed and Breakfast,
ein Hofladen mit frischen,
selbstgemachten Produkten
und ein Hobbylandwirtschaftsbetrieb
mit eigenen Tieren.
* Sanftes Glockenbimmeln *
Es ist ein Traum,
der in Erfüllung geht.
Das kann man kaum beschreiben.
Salome und ich haben,
seit wir uns kennen,
so etwas gesucht.
Wir haben lange gesucht,
um so etwas zu finden.
Wir sind seit mehreren Jahren
aktiv dran,
und jetzt hat es sich so ergeben.
Neu ist, dass sie zusätzlich
einen richtigen Bauernbetrieb
mit 14 Milchkühen übernehmen.
Wir hatten zu Hause
schon immer Kühe,
und später noch Schafe.
Das sind alles Dinge,
die wir von zu Hause kennen.
Um das Grundeinkommen
für die junge Familie zu sichern,
arbeitete Thom
bis jetzt zusätzlich auswärts.
Hey, kleine Maus!
Hast du Hunger?
Jetzt gibt's was, gell, Müsli-Büsli.
Hallo, hoi. Hoi.
Bis sie ihren Hof übernehmen können,
bleibt es in den nächsten Monaten so.
Es ist noch warm, gell?
Ja, was auf uns zukommt,
ist sicher anstrengend.
Aber wenn man versucht,
es gut zu planen,
und früh genug beginnt,
sollte es machbar sein.
Wir haben schon ziemlich viel
gemacht und sind gut dran.
Und doch schaudert es einen ab und
zu: "Wie schaffen wir das wohl?"
Aber das geht schon irgendwie.
Unsere Einstellung: positiv denken.
Dann geht es meistens irgendwie.
Maus, du musst trinken!
* Ruhige Klaviermusik,
Glockenläuten *
Zum letzten Mal
hält er heute eine Predigt:
Peter Christen,
Pfarrer von Ostermundigen.
Mit 65 geht er in Rente.
Es ist das letzte Mal,
und jetzt merke ich es plötzlich.
Es ist so ein Abschluss,
ein Break,
auf den ich lange hingelebt habe,
und jetzt ist er plötzlich da,
weisst du?
Jetzt wir es langsam kribbelig.
Hallo zusammen!
Ciao. Ciao, hoi.
Guten Morgen miteinander.
27 Jahre lang
war er mit Leib und Seele Pfarrer.
Schön, bist du hier.
* Fröhliche
Trompeten- und Orgelmusik *
* Rhythmische Beats *
Während Peter Christens Abschied
immer näher rückt,
geniesst seine Nachfolgerin,
Aline Berger,
noch ihre Freiheit
am Open Air Gampel.
Aha, ihr kommt von dort!
Bis gleich!
Ich freue mich auf die Musik,
obwohl ich gar nicht so genau weiss,
wer eigentlich spielt.
Und darauf, wieder mal ein wenig
in meiner Peer Group zu sein,
mit den Gleichaltrigen.
Ein Szenenwechsel zum Kirch-
gemeindehaus. Ich freue mich drauf.
Hallo, Vreni!
- Hallo!
Aline Berger ist 27 - jung, voller
eigener Ideen und Vorstellungen
und kurz davor,
ihre Ausbildung abzuschliessen.
Und mein Zelt
ist wirklich ultralight.
* Rhythmischer Mundartpop:
"Mis Huus dis Huus" von Lo & Leduc *
Vieles wird Aline sicher
anders machen als ihr Vorgänger,
und ihre Rolle als neue Pfarrerin der
Gemeinde muss sie erst noch finden.
# Trotz auem seisch du mir Fründ,
trotz auem seisch du mir Fründ.
# U drum sägi dir:
Mis Härz isch es Hotel.
# (Publikum) Mis Huus dis Huus,
# (Alle) O we mir üs
sit Jahre nid ghört hei.
Gut 27 1/2 Jahre ist es her.
Vieles ist passiert,
es gab viel Rauf und Runter.
Manchmal Zweifel dran, ob es gut ist
oder ob es vielleicht klüger wäre,
ich würde Buschauffeur
oder wieder Dachdecker werden,
oder irgend so was.
Und trotzdem:
Ich bin hiergeblieben.
Auch hier, in dieser Gemeinde.
Ich freue mich sehr fest,
dass Sie sich alle
haben einladen lassen
und heute Morgen
hierhergekommen sind,
um Gottesdienst zu feiern,
ein Fest zu feiern.
# Mis Härz isch es Hotel.
# (Publikum) Mis Huus dis Huus.
# O we mir üs
sit Jahre nid ghört hei.
# Mis Huus dis Huus.
* Jubel *
* Altmodische Fahrradhupe *
Als Velopfarrer
war Peter Christen bekannt.
Deshalb auch das Abschiedsgeschenk,
das er von Matthias Jäggi,
Leiter des Pfarrteams Ostermundigen,
bekommt.
Wenn du das ...
Nein, noch nicht, noch nicht!
Noch nicht?
- Noch nicht.
Du kannst auch draufsitzen, aber
ich möchte noch etwas dazu sagen.
Wenn man davon ausgeht,
dass du jeden Tag
zweimal runter ins Dorf
und wieder rauf gefahren bist,
und das
ist sicher nicht überschätzt,
dann waren es rund 40'880 Male,
in denen du mit dem Fahrrad
durchs Dorf gefahren bist.
Und kaum sahst du jemanden,
den du kanntest -
oder auch nicht kanntest ...
- Ja, genau.
... das war manchmal
eigentlich relativ egal -
hast du gewunken,
"Hallo!" und "Hoi zäme!"
oder hast irgendjemandem
hinterhergepfiffen.
Du hattest zu allen
einen guten Draht.
Das ist doch schön.
Es gab immer auch eine Umarmung
hier, ein Küsschen dort
und nochmals ein Küsschen dort. Du
warst wirklich mitten in den Leuten.
* Feierliche Orgelmusik *
Der Hemdenverkäufer aus Bern,
Markus Hauser,
ist mit seinem alten Freund Otto
in Paris auf Einkaufstour.
Das ComeBack
ist Markus Hausers Laden in Bern.
Rock 'n' Roll und Hemden
sind seine Passion.
Vor 24 Jahren erfüllte er sich
den Traum des eigenen Hemdenladens.
Jetzt ist er 72
und sucht einen Nachfolger.
* Rockige Gitarrenriffs *
Hallo, Mieze.
Bist du immer noch hier?
* Lautes Schnurren *
Seit 24 Jahren ist er im Herbst
jeweils in Paris auf Einkaufstour
und besucht drei Tage lang
seine Händler.
Er wohnt immer im gleichen Hotel.
Ja.
Es ist einfach praktisch,
weil man schnell auf der Arbeit ist.
Und es ist zentral
und hat gute Beizen etc.
in der Nähe.
Aber vieles hat sich in Paris
in all den Jahren stark verändert.
Siehst du,
die meisten Lokale sind zu, fertig.
Ja, hier ist alles zugenagelt.
- Ja, da kommst du nicht rein.
Ja ...
Hier kamst du nie so schnell durch,
überall musste man schauen:
Was bietet der an, was hat der?
Das ist durch.
Ja. Alles ist im Wandel.
- Ja.
Ganze Ladenstrassen mussten schlies-
sen, weil es nicht mehr rentierte
und sie dem Druck von Onlinehandel
und grossen Ladenketten
nicht standhielten.
Auch Markus musste immer wieder neue
Händler suchen und Kontakte aufbauen.
Alors, ça va, Markus?
- Ça va très bien, merci.
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait? C'est quoi?
Das muss ich umtauschen,
das ist zu gross.
Ça c'est trop grand.
Ça, tout ça.
- Les quatre?
Oui.
Es hat viele schöne Hemden hier.
Ich kann nicht sagen, wie viele
ich nehme, denn ich muss ...
Fast all diese.
Mal sehen, wie viele es dann sind.
Ich habe kein Budget
für eine bestimmte Anzahl Hemden.
Ich nehme so viele,
wie mir gefallen.
Paisleymuster
sind jedes Mal gefragt,
Blumenmuster sind immer gefragt.
Genau das müssen wir haben.
Das nicht.
- Ça non?
Fünf Farben?
- Un, deux, trois, quatre, cinq.
Ah, c'est ça. Oui.
Donc oui ou non?
- Non.
Ist das dasselbe?
- Oui. Tu veux que je te la déplie?
Non, ça va bien, merci.
- Je peux t'aider, Markus.
Les deux. Diese beiden nehme ich.
Il est top, Markus.
Markus ist absolut top.
Er ist seriös, anständig.
Was er will, will er. Das ist prak-
tisch, so verlieren wir keine Zeit.
Das ist sehr gut.
Er kennt sein Metier.
Oui, ça c'est bon.
- Ç'est très beau.
Je prends toujours
une fois comme ça.
Ah, oui.
- Sept.
Diese Exklusivität schätzen auch
seine Kunden in der Schweiz.
Deshalb ist Markus überzeugt,
dass sein Geschäft auch heute noch
eine Marktlücke füllt.
Ça, c'est bon.
- Ça, c'est bon.
Ich habe jetzt 2'615 Euro bezahlt.
Etwa 100 ... 130.
All seine Erfahrung
und seine Kontakte
würde er seinem Nachfolger natürlich
weitergeben - wenn er einen findet.
Okay.
* Melodiöse, dynamische Musik *
Im Emmental wird umgezogen.
Unterstützung erhalten Wielands
von Peter ...
... und von Andreas.
* Unverständliches Gespräch *
Wielands
bieten auch betreutes Wohnen an,
für Mitbewohner mit körperlicher
und geistiger Beeinträchtigung.
Es ist toll, dass sie hier sind,
wirklich mega schön.
Es ist sehr schön,
das gemeinsam zu erleben -
als Familie, auch mit ihnen,
ist eine wunderschöne Sache.
* Fröhliche, leichte Klänge *
Peter und Andreas gehören inzwischen
fest zur Familie Wieland
und ziehen mir ihr ins neue Zuhause.
* Die Musik wird dynamischer. *
Das ist er,
der zukünftige Hof von Wielands,
im tiefen Emmental,
in Röthenbach bei der Grub.
* Fröhliche, dynamische Musik,
unverständliches Gespräch *
Thom ist inzwischen unterwegs
mit Ernst Lehmann,
dem Bauern,
der ihnen den Hof verkauft hat.
Ernst zeigt Thom die 14 Milchkühe,
die sie übernehmen.
Man könnte meinen,
ihr kennt mich nicht.
Die kennen dich schon.
Ja, ja.
- Wer der Meister ist.
Sollten sie! Mit dieser hier
musste ich immer kämpfen.
Gehorchte sie nicht?
- Sie benahm sich nicht beim Melken.
Aber jetzt ist gut.
Ist sie ruhiger geworden?
- Ja, jetzt geht's ganz gut.
Ein Leben lang war Ernst hier Bauer,
jetzt musste er den Hof verkaufen.
* Leichte Streichmusik *
Die einen müssen,
die anderen wollen.
Martin Sigg ist seit 35 Jahren
Hausarzt in Hergiswil,
wird nächstes Jahr 70
und sucht jetzt einen Nachfolger.
Heute
gehen wir einen Patienten besuchen,
dann gehen wir zurück in die Praxis
und sehen dort wieder Patienten.
(Mann) Wer ist da?
- Sigg.
* Surren *
Merci!
Jeden Dienstagnachmittag
besucht er seine Patienten zu Hause.
Grüezi, Herr Buser.
In Zukunft aber möchte er
frei vom verplanten Leben sein.
Ja, gut.
- Ist das mein Zeug da?
Hier habe ich Ihre Medikamente, ja.
Soll ich sie auf den Tisch legen?
Das wäre gut.
- Gut, ja.
Und, wie geht es Ihnen?
- Immer gleich.
Darf ich schnell hier abstellen?
- Ja, ja.
Ja.
Also.
130/72. Das ist gut.
Das ist gut.
Kommt die Spitex jeden Tag zu Ihnen?
- Nein, nein, nein.
Nicht?
- Das habe ich abbestellt.
Dreimal?
Seit es mit der Wunde besser ist?
Viermal.
- Viermal noch, ja.
Montag, Dienstag, Donnerstag
und Samstag. - Mhm, prima.
Dann komme ich in etwa einem Monat
wieder, in Ordnung? - Das ist recht.
Alles Gute, Herr Huser.
- Vielen Dank.
Er gibt mir Sicherheit, dass ich ...
... dass ich weiterleben kann.
Ich muss wahrscheinlich schon
einen anderen Arzt nehmen, aber ...
... ob der auch Hausbesuche macht,
weiss ich ja nicht.
Und gehen kann ich nicht mehr.
Also ... Ich kann noch
ins Schlafzimmer gehen,
das ist gerade so das Maximum,
dann ist wieder fertig.
Wenn ich aufhöre, schaue ich, dass
ich jemanden finde, der Sie besucht.
Wir schauen schon, dass Sie ...
... nicht irgendwo alleine
braten müssen. - Ja.
Nein, das ist auch mein Lebensziel,
wenn ich aufhöre, wissen Sie.
Da müssen Sie sich
keine Sorgen machen.
Eben, ja. Das ist gut.
- Fein.
Herr Doktor, alles Gute.
- Alles Gute.
Danke. Lassen Sie das nur.
- Hier ist er auch gut aufgehoben.
Prima. Adieu!
- Auf Wiedersehen.
Das hat mich sehr berührt.
Mir war nicht bewusst,
wie wichtig ihm ein Besuch ist.
Das habe ich erst heute gehört.
Dass er das überhaupt schätzt.
Denn er ist ein Mann ... ohne grosse
Emotionen, im Grunde genommen.
Mich hat es berührt, zu sehen,
wie er eben doch einsam ist.
Vor mir sagte er jeweils,
es sei kein Problem.
Aber jetzt ist er doch
eher nahe am Wasser gebaut.
Und zeigt schon,
wie einsam er wirklich ist.
Man wird an die Endlichkeit erinnert
und denkt:
"Wie geht es mir, wenn wenn ich alt
bin? Bin ich dann auch so einsam?"
Ich glaube und hoffe es nicht.
Das ist es.
* Schwere, melodiöse Musik *
Im Emmental fährt Salome Ladung
um Ladung vom alten ins neue Zuhause
nach Röthenbach,
das nur gerade 10 km entfernt liegt.
Das wohl Wichtigste,
was wir an den neuen Ort mitnehmen:
Wir müssen schauen, dass wir
alles unter einen Hut bringen.
Nicht das Gefühl zu haben, wir
müssten oder wollen alles machen,
sondern dass wir auch
zu uns als Familie schauen,
zusammen mit unseren Mitbewohnern.
Dass wir es uns nicht vergraulen,
sondern die Freude beibehalten
und nicht so viel loshaben,
dass es uns keine Freude mehr macht.
Grenzen setzen zu können.
Das ist das Wichtigste.
Landwirtschaft, Kühe - alles unter
einem Hut. Sonst ist's kaum machbar.
Das Glück von Wielands ist eng ver-
bunden mit Ernst Lehmanns Schicksal.
Eine der Schönsten.
- Auch eine sehr schöne.
Das Guschti hier.
- Gibt schön Milch.
Ernst ist erst 57.
Er ist auf diesem Hof geboen.
Jetzt muss er ihn aus
gesundheitlichen Gründen aufgeben.
1999 hatte ich Chemo.
Und zwar eigentlich
in einem massiven ...
... Endstadium. Sie sagten mir
immer, es sei fünf vor zwölf.
Es könne in beide Richtungen gehen.
2006 hatte ich dann
einen geplatzten Enddarm.
Mitten in der Nacht.
Da holte mich auch die Ambulanz
und ich bin ...
... ins Koma gefallen.
Ich habe eigentlich
mein fünftes Leben.
Und dann letzten November
der Sturz von der Heubühne.
Der hat
markante Änderungen gebracht.
Seit Generationen
gehörte der Hof Familie Lehmann.
Als es Ernst schlecht ging, übernahm
seine Frau Lydia immer mehr Arbeiten,
bis es nicht mehr ging und sie
einen Nachfolger suchen mussten.
Über 19 Bewerber haben sich gemeldet.
* Entspannte Klänge *
Zuletzt hatten wir drei Bewerber,
die wir nach erster, zweiter,
dritter Wahl eingestuft hatten.
Thom und Salome
waren an erster Stelle,
dann ein junges Paar,
das im September geheiratet hat
und an zweiter Stelle gewesen wäre.
Dann haben wir im Gebet gefragt,
wer es sein soll.
Wir fanden,
dass beide Paare geeignet wären,
und beide hätten sich gefreut.
Dann habe ich geträumt, dass
Thomas und Salome hierhin ziehen.
Das war für mich eine Art ...
Hinweis.
Wow.
Lydia und Ernst
haben einen sehr starken Glauben,
der ihnen in diesen Zeiten
immer geholfen hat
und jetzt
Zuversicht für die Zukunft gibt.
* Sanfte Streichmusik *
In Hergiswil
gehört es zu Martin Siggs Aufgabe,
seine Patienten
auch noch zu betreuen,
wenn sie ins Altersheim
oder die Seniorenresidenz kommen.
Als Hausarzt
hat er sie ein Leben lang begleitet.
(Frau) Es ist offen!
Guten Tag, Herr Doktor!
Danke, Herr Doktor, ich freue mich.
- Grüezi, Frau Szabo.
Wie geht es Ihnen?
- Nehmen Sie bitte Platz.
Gut, danke. Ich bin nur traurig
wegen Frau Niederberger.
Das hat mich sehr getroffen.
Das ist ... schade.
Und Ihnen geht es gut?
Das ist auch wichtig.
Doch, danke, ich bin zufrieden.
Ich bin froh, dass ich Sie sehe.
Sonst geht es mir gut.
Ich mache immer etwas, aber es wird
immer schwieriger wegen den Augen.
Aber durch diese neunmonatige
Krankheit, die ich hatte,
bin ich nicht
zum Augenarzt gegangen.
Soll ich Sie anmelden?
- Ja.
Mein ehemaliger Augenarzt
ist bereit pensioniert.
Ja.
Eine Ärztin,
an der Zentralstrasse in Luzern.
Ja, ja.
- Vielen Dank, Herr Doktor.
Das ist meine einzige Beschwerde.
Da bin ich froh,
das macht es einfach für mich.
Wir kennen uns schon über 30 Jahre.
Innen und aussen.
Ich möchte gerne, dass der Herr
Doktor lange genug da bleibt.
Ich weiss schon,
dass die Zeit kommt, aber ...
Für ihn wäre es gut,
aber für uns ist es nicht so gut.
Und wir haben uns so gern.
Also ich habe ihn gern.
Mein Mann auch.
- Das ist gegenseitig.
Ihr Mann auch, ja.
- Mein Mann auch.
Er ist leider
vor zwei Jahren gestorben.
Entschuldigung,
ich habe Sie unterbrochen.
Nein, nein. Sie sagten, Sie haben
mich gern, ich habe Sie auch gern.
Ja.
- Wir kennen uns schon so lange.
Es ist wirklich süss:
Sie schickt mir immer zu Weihnachten
eine Karte, nicht wahr?
Mhm.
- Adieu.
Danke, Herr Doktor.
- Alles Gute.
Ja. Schöne Grüsse an Ihre Frau.
- Sage ich, danke.
Bitteschön. Ade.
- Adieu.
* Rockige Klänge *
In Paris geht die Einkaufstour
von Markus Hauser
und seinem Freund Otto zu Ende.
Wenn Markus einen Nachfolger findet,
war er vielleicht das letzt Mal hier
als Besitzer und Einkäufer
für sein Geschäft.
Uiuiui.
Fehlt nur noch das Bier.
- Das Bier, ja.
Ich habe das
jetzt bald 50 Jahre gemacht.
Aber es gibt Neues.
Ein anderes Leben, das auch gut
sein wird - wenn man gesund bleibt.
Ich glaube,
das wird gut vonstatten gehen.
Er ist ein Typ, der loslassen kann.
Das ist er. Ich glaube schon, ja.
Ich stelle es mir auch so vor,
aber wenn es dann
wirklich so weit ist ...
Es ist schon Herzblut,
das verloren geht.
Ja. Aber das ist ...
- Aber ich glaube, das geht gut.
Ja. Du ...
- Ich will ja.
Ich müsste ja nicht, ich will ja.
Das Leben noch mit Erinnerungen
zu geniessen, ist mir wichtig.
Ja.
- Würde ich alleine leben ...
... ein sog. Single wäre,
würde ich nicht an so etwas denken.
Dann würde ich
einfach weiterarbeiten,
ohne Ziel, ohne:
"Noch fünf Jahre, noch zehn Jahre."
Das weiss man ja nicht.
Die Gesundheit ist wichtig.
Die Situation ist gut, wie sie ist.
Es ist Zeit, etwas Neues zu machen.
Ja, und eben: Eine Tür geht zu,
eine neue geht auf.
Ich finde es toll.
Das finde ich wirklich super.
Und er schafft das problemlos.
Ja. Und das wünsche ich ihm.
Merci.
- Bitte.
Gerne.
- Gerne. Ja, gut.
Merci bien.
- Bière parisienne.
C'est vrai?
- Oui.
Gesundheit.
- Zum Wohl, Markus. Alles Gute.
Zum Wohl.
Aline Berger
hat heute ihren ersten Arbeitstag
als Pfarrerin von Ostermundigen.
* Dynamische Klänge, Glocken *
Genau.
Ich glaube, es ist hier hinten.
Ach, hier hätte es
auch noch Parkplätze gehabt.
Grüessech!
- Ach! Ciao Peter.
Begrüsst wird sie von Peter Christen,
ihrem Vorgänger.
... das Velo abstellen sollte.
Und vom Leiter des Pfarrteams
Ostermundigen, Matthias Jäggi.
Schau.
- Ah, ja.
Dein Büro ist noch nicht
ganz original angeschrieben.
Immerhin
steht Peter Christen drunter.
Aber mit einem Papier
vorübergehend überdeckt.
Ich sagte noch zu Marlies:
"Du kannst nicht Peter
stehen lassen, wenn Aline kommt."
- (Peter) Klar.
- Aber der Maler kommt.
Das ist nicht deiner, aber du kannst
das Büro trotzdem selber öffnen.
Den brauche ich wieder,
sonst habe ich ein Problem.
(Peter) Hast du gehört?
Der piepst jedes Mal!
Das hat's bei mir nie gemacht.
- Weil es fremder Schlüssel ist?
* Peter imitiert das Piepsen. *
(Aline) Oh, ja.
Nein, es sind bloss neue Schlösser,
eine neue Schliessanlage.
# I schänke dir mis Hä...
Eh, Sandstein aus Ostermundigen.
Oh, danke!
Die mag ich sehr. Vielen Dank!
Süss.
- Die werden nicht lange leben.
Ich habe extra noch für dich
ein neues Telefon angeschafft.
Und wenn du eine Nummer suchst musst
du runter, und dann kommen sie.
Schau,
Christen Gabriel, Christen Peter.
"Löschen" - dann ist er weg,
der Peter Christen.
Das war jetzt ein Symbolakt.
Dich rausgelöscht.
Schau, dafür bist du drin.
- Ja.
Und jetzt wäre sozusagen
deine erste Amtshandlung,
eine eigenen Ansage für
den Telefonbeantworter zu machen.
Ja.
Ich habe es immer so gemacht,
dass ich meine Handynummer
dort angegeben habe.
Für den Notfall. Dann mussten sie
zuerst überlegen ...
Das werde ich nicht machen.
- ... ist das jetzt ein Notfall?
Du musst es nicht so machen.
Das ist ...
* Leichte Streichmusik *
Gehen wir einen Kaffee trinken?
- Ja.
Martin Sigg hat in all den Jahren
seine Rituale aufgebaut -
auch als Chef.
Ja, gerne.
Dazu gehört der tägliche Kaffee
mit seinen Praxisassistentinnen.
Du hast ihr Medikamente abgegeben,
Antibiotika, Schmerzmedis.
Sie hatte
eine extrem schlechte Nacht
und hat gesagt, sie nehme
diese Sachen jetzt nicht mehr.
Nur, damit du informiert bist.
Ich habe doch
keine Antibiotika gegeben.
Am Telefon hat sie das so gesagt.
Das ... Ja, das ist überzeugend.
Sie hatte ein Schmerzmittel.
Sie hatte ein Novalgin.
Mhm.
Das hat sie sicher abgesetzt.
Und ich habe ihr gesagt,
eigentlich müsste sie jetzt ...
... eine Auszeit nehmen.
Denn das sind psychosomatische
Beschwerden mit ihrer neuen Chefin,
die aber dummerweise
noch die Freundin des Chefs ist.
Deshalb habe sie gar nichts
zu sagen. Die mache nichts.
Und sie ist ein Workaholic und
ist froh, dass sie jetzt Arbeit hat.
Sie kann keine Auszeit nehmen, weil
sie endlich eine Festanstellung hat.
Wenn sie aufhört, wird sie
die wahrscheinlich verlieren.
Das ist ihr Dilemma. Und sie wird
immer kranker, bis sie aufhört.
Das habe ich ihr so gesagt.
Mal schauen.
Die Patienten werden ...
extrem traurig sein.
Denn ... sie haben dich so gern,
als Mensch und als Arzt.
Es bedeutet ihnen extrem viel,
jemanden zu haben, der ...
Er muss die Patienten nur anschauen
und kennt schon ihren Lebenslauf,
was bei ihnen passiert ist.
Und das ist so viel wert.
Sie schätzen das
und es wird ihnen fehlen.
Das macht die Nachfolgersuche
auch für Martin Sigg schwierig.
Ich wünschte mir,
dass er Freude an seinem Beruf hat.
Dass er Freude am Menschen hat,
dass er Freude am Zuhören hat.
Denn man lernt
unglaublich spannende Sachen kennen.
Und zwar nicht nur von persönlichen
Schicksalen, auch bildungsmässig.
Es gibt hochinteressante Menschen,
die Einblick in neue Welten geben.
Das kommt mit der Zeit,
wenn man sie besser kennt.
Was ich mir
von meinem Nachfolger erhoffe:
dass er weiterhin bereit ist,
Leute auch zu Hause zu besuchen.
Denn das ist wertvoll - für die
Patienten ebenso wie für den Arzt.
Denn erst dann sehe ich richtig,
wie diese Menschen leben.
Zwei Hausärzte gingen in Hergiswil
in den letzten Jahren in Rente.
Nur einer fand einen Nachfolger.
Darum hat sich jetzt
die Gemeinde eingeschaltet
und eine Agentur beauftragt, die für
Martin Sigg aktiv Nachfolger sucht
und sie an ihn verweist.
Letztlich entscheidet er.
Ich bin momentan im Gespräch mit ...
... vier Personen, wobei zwei
sehr interessiert scheinen.
Ich bin eigentlich guter Hoffnung,
dass ich mein Ziel erreichen kann.
Ohne Nachfolger für Martin Sigg
läuft Hergiswil
in eine Hausarzt-Unterversorgung.
In Ostermundigen muss Aline
ihre Privatsphäre definieren.
Wie macht ihr das jetzt? Hat das ir-
gendwie Einfluss auf die Telefonie?
Das müssen wir mit dir regeln.
Ich schaue mal, wie's geht -
bis dahin den Gemeindemitgliedern
die Nummer möglichst nicht geben.
- Das geht gut.
Ich kenne eben eine junge Pfarrerin,
die dann einen Stalker hatte,
der ihr dauernd SMS schickte, sie
musste u.a. ihre Nummer wechseln.
Vielleicht ist es für junge Frauen
etwas anders.
Bei dir ist eher die Frage, wie ...
Ich habe das Gefühl, wie ...
Wie viele Male du rund um die Uhr
erreichbar sein möchtest.
Genau.
- Und was da alles kommt.
Und wer zu welcher Zeit etwas will.
Ich glaube, das ist hier das Thema.
Dass die Leute ...
- Beim Berufseinstieg ...
"Was bedeutet es jetzt?"
- Mhm.
Ich weiss noch nicht genau, wie ich
mit den Jugendlichen stehen werde.
Wenn es innerhalb des Jobs ist,
würde ich auch mit ihnen WhatsAppen.
Es geht immer mehr übers Handy.
Braucht man also sein privates
oder hat man noch ein anderes?
Die Vermischung von Privatem und
Beruf gibt's in vielen Branchen.
Auch Lydia und Ernst ziehen um: Sie
ziehen ins gegenüberliegende Wohnhaus
und räumen jetzt ihr Bauernhaus.
Was auch mitkommt:
die Bilder der Pflegekinder,
die bei ihnen aufgewachsen sind
und zur Familie gehören.
Eigene Kinder
hatten Lydia und Ernst nie.
Es war schön in diesem Wohnzimmer,
aber ich richte mir das neue
auch wieder gemütlich ein,
sodass mir wohl ist.
Hier ist ein Kinderzimmer.
Das sind alles
bereits Möbel von Wielands,
die in diese Räume gestellt werden.
Das ist unser Schlafzimmer,
auch schon ziemlich geräumt.
Bilder und Schrank sind weg,
wir haben nur noch eine Kiste
mit Kleidern, die noch hier sind.
Das kommt morgen hoch.
Diese Nacht ist die letzte,
die wir hier verbringen werden.
Als wir im Wohnzimmer waren,
dachte ich noch:
Als wir geheiratet haben,
im April '87,
habe ich das Wohnzimmer
so angetroffen: ganz leer.
Und es hatte keine Vorhänge.
Die habe ich genäht.
Das ging so schnell vorbei.
31 Jahre sind doch eine lange Zeit,
wenn man so überlegt.
Und jetzt geben wir es weiter.
Und schauen, wie's nachher aussieht.
Die Chefin arbeitet
und ich schaue zu.
Das Leben geht einfach weiter.
- Ja.
So ist einfach das Leben.
- Ja, das ist so.
Es ist zwar noch etwas früh für uns,
aber ...
... eben.
Irgendwann wäre es sowieso gekommen.
Ich denke, es ist jetzt gut so.
Das waren etwas grobe Nägel.
Lydia und Ernst unterstützen
ihre Nachfolger anfangs noch.
Dort hat es noch irgendwo
eine Stecknadel.
Ja, gut, danke!
Und dir?
In der nächsten Folge:
Salome hat das Wohnzimmer
schon für Gäste und Events umgebaut.
Ein turbulenter Start für Thom
ins neue Leben als Profibauer.
Am 3. Januar ist der Sturm Burglind
durch die Schweiz gefegt
und hat auch bei uns
Spuren hinterlassen.
Martin Sigg ist auf der Jagd -
sein grosses Hobby.
Aber ein Nachfolger
ist nicht in Sicht.
Ich glaube, er wird weiterarbeiten.
Er wird niemanden finden
für seine Praxis.
Guten Morgen.
- Guten Morgen!
Aline zeigt in der ersten Predigt,
was die Gemeinde erwartet.
Schön, bist du hier!
Dass dieser erste Mensch kein Mann,
sondern ein geschlechtsloses,
ein intersexuelles Wesen war.
Das und mehr in der nächsten Folge
von "Abenteuer Nachfolge".